[Musique]
avril 2008 vladimir poutine arrive à
bucarest en roumanie pour assister au
premier sommet otan-russie
en principe le sommet de la détente mais
c'est là que tout a commencé à mal
tourner pour le président russe car
l'otan vient d'annoncer qu'après la
croatie et l'albanie l'ukraine et la
géorgie deviendront membres mais pas
tout de suite
c'en est trop pour vladimir poutine il
est de mauvaise humeur mais il se
retient alors que george w bush lui
visiblement joyeux pourtant le président
russe lui a déjà dit georges vous devez
comprendre que l'ukraine ait même pas un
vrai pays
l'apparition d'un bloc puissant à nos
frontières qui sera considéré en russie
comme une menace directe contre votre
sécurité
ce que le président ukrainien conteste
l'ukraine n'est pas un produit de la
guerre froide elle est un état
indépendant souverain
un mois plus tard vladimir poutine cède
le pouvoir à dmitri medvedev mais il
devient son premier ministre ça ne
change rien au plan de riposte à
l'affront de l'otan début août l'armée
russe a envahi la géorgie occupe le ceti
du sud puis l'abkhazie en soutien alors
rebelle pro-russe le conflit sera rude
mais bref moscou reconnaît les deux
régions géorgiennes cambrai public
autonome 26 août 2008 et on interdit
l'accès aux occidentaux
pour l'ukraine ce sera une autre paire
de manches car le pro russe viktor
ianoukovitch étaient lues en 2010 fin
2013 il renverse la décision ukrainienne
de se joindre à l'union européenne et à
l'otan
les ukrainiens nationaliste se révoltent
et ce sera le drame de la révolution de
maidan la répression fera plus de 80
morts
fortement contesté ianoukovitch s'enfuit
en russie il sera destitué
mais les tensions entre nationalistes et
les éléments pro russe d'ukraine
s'accroissent et la révolte éclate dans
le dôme basse et la crimée
la crimée surtout peuplé par des russes
qui sur la foi d'un référendum
unilatéral largement remporté réclament
l'adhésion à la russie
l'occupation se fera par des petits
hommes verts des soldats sans aucune
marque d'appartenance et l'annexion
suivra sans aucun combat ratifiée par le
président poutine le 3 mars 2014
john bass et séparatiste pro-russe et
l'armée ukrainienne se battront jusqu'à
maintenant faisant quatorze mille
victimes l'occident réagi par des
sanctions
des sanctions qui ont levé aujourd'hui
auront été inefficace avec un front
occidental affaibli par le président
donald trump en admiration devant
vladimir poutine
encore une fois la dîmière poutine a été
sous-estimée on a sous-estimé son sens
de l'histoire et la rancune causés par
le démantèlement de l'empiré soviétique
pour cet ancien agent du kgb son désir
de vengeance également
on a rapporté qu'angela merkel qu'il
connaissait bien a dit de lui qu'il
avait perdu contact avec la réalité et
qu'il vivait dans son monde
récemment l'entourage des manuels macron
le décrit comme rigide et paranoïaque
est de plus en plus isolé qu'il ne
serait plus le même que celui qui l'a
rencontré en 2019
supposer que cet homme calculateur se
contenterait de fragments de l'ancien
empire
dans une basse et la crimée comme pour
la georgie en 2008
ne croyez pas qu'il se risquerait d'en
ainsi énorme coup de poker